PROFESSOR: So in the
last part of the course,
we'll discuss the fluid
mechanics of indoor spaces,
in particular, going
beyond the approximation
of a well-mixed room when
considering airborne disease
transmission.
So for example, we will
consider the occupants
of a room and their
respiratory activity.
So when they breathe, especially
if they're not wearing a mask,
or if they cough, they're
going to have turbulent plumes
emitting from their
mouth, which will then
be convected throughout
the room and will influence
other people.
Also, the heat of the
body relative to the room
can lead to warmer air, which
is rising, so that essentially
sort of a chimney
of a thermal plume
rising from an individual.
Those heterogeneities
in the flow
and in the concentration
of aerosol particles
may not always be well-mixed.
We'll talk about different
types of ventilation,
how, for example, cold air
will sink from the place
where it's inserted
and warm air will rise.
And that may or may
not lead to sufficient
mixing to remain well-mixed.
And we'll talk about how
to modify our criterion
for airborne
disease transmission
in a well-mixed room to account
for some of these changes,
in particular the heightened
risk of short-range
transmission from being
directly in the path
of respiratory puffs
and plumes emanating
from an infected person.